then what brought you to Los Angeles oh
ok so I was working this job as a
salesman I was working for a company
called FairPoint communications and you
know a typical Turner burn middle
management job and I was selling home
services businesses and after time went
on I started to have this realization
that like this is it this is what you do
you know you get out of college get that
job they promised you little management
you hate life and you don't make any
money it wasn't a good paying sales job
it was one of those you know entry-level
out of college jobs and so I've working
on ours unhappy and I've been work out a
movie script some friends and I they say
hey let's go out try to sell it I didn't
know anything about movies or how to
sell one but I think that I just wanted
to get out there and do something
different I thought this was my one shot
to do something different because you
know Connecticut wasn't going to fall
into the ocean he sound think so al gore
might disagree with me but I thought
let's go for you know we can always go
home so I came out to LA that's for
began as a child did you have
aspirations to be in the entertainment
industry or were you hoping for the
normal white picket fence and the safe
life that's funny you'd ask it like that
when I was in the fourth grade I
remember falling in love with radio I
was listening to this Bon Jovi song and
I wanted to hear it again and so this
thing was sup living out of prayer and
so I kept calling up q 105 and rot
nobody would play my damn song I started
getting pissy with it DJ's this is one
guy his name was Tom timmons and I
always remember them because I just
thought he was a coolest guy in the
world he was probably miserable making
minimum wage but to a kid who's in the
fourth grade it seemed like the coolest
thing in the world and Tom Timmons
played my song he played it for me and I
had this this old boom box with a one
tape deck one speaker plays in mono
and I waited for it wait for it and I
didn't even know the beginning of the
song because all the djs talk too much
they talk over the beginning of the song
and my brother already said not to
beginning of the song I recorded it and
I just thought that was the coolest
thing and I want to be a DJ so my
initial your dream job was be a DJ on
radio but then I got older I figured I
would do some kind of a corporate job
and I did have this white picket fence
fantasy that you're talking about I
senior will says something about I want
to live in a small town and marry a nice
conservative girl and very Americana and
I even remember when I was a junior in
high school getting in an argument with
this girl who made the argument that you
had to go to lipid city yeah I'd go to
the city live there because that's where
you would see all these different
ethnicities and cultures and that was
superior to this small town living and I
remember arguing with her and I
specifically reference Los Angeles and
so I will never live there so much for
that because I've been out here since
two thousand and never contemplated
going back do you remember that day that
you drove into LA I remember the six
days because there's a long drive I
remember vaguely I know this means
anything near the 210 freeway it was at
night we come from Phoenix so it was the
last leg of a long journey and it was
pretty easy one the thing that I
remember most about that first night was
getting to the apartment with my three
friends and then realizing that the damn
place had no refrigerator that was a
that was one of those moments where they
got to see me get angry I was just
pissed who rents an apartment with no
refrigerator how to washer/dryer them no
refrigerator then on top of it they
wouldn't accept our check said no it's
got to be a cashier's check like gluten
what do you think a look
yeah screw you at anyone what we're
going to go back you know but I now that
I'm older I understand the whole concept
of how hard it is to evict somebody get
a squatter in your house and you can't
get them out for six months because the
laws are designed to protect criminals
but at the time I didn't know that this
was insane so then we had to go and stay
in a wrote some Motel the vagabond inn
that was fun yeah one of the guys didn't
want to pay the payment for one more
night so we slept out the truck and it
was just not a pleasant but I remember
my first night that was my first night
in LA
you